[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the rumors surrounding a new
harry potter tv show that will appear on
hbo
the rumors first began circulating at
the end of last year
and since then have been in a perpetual
cycle of being shot down
then reaffirmed the original article
stated
the following a harry potter live-action
tv series
is in early development at hbo max
sources tell the hollywood reporter that
executives at the warner media
backstreamer
have engaged in multiple conversations
with potential writers
exploring various ideas that would bring
the beloved property to television
sources say broad ideas have been
discussed as part of the early stage
exploratory meetings
at first i thought this is too good to
be true but then i considered that harry
potter is perhaps warner brothers most
popular ip
so why wouldn't they make a show i
started fantasizing about all the
possibilities for the new show
could it cover voldemort's origins how
about the marauders
then i discovered that things were still
very early on
while it's news that executives at hbo
max and warner's are engaged in meetings
to find a writer and pitch for a harry
potter tv series
no writers or talents are currently
attached as the conversations are still
in the extremely early stages and no
deals have been made
but even after hearing that my hopes
remained will i get to see the origins
of some of my favorite characters
well as it turns out that's not going to
be the case at least
not for now there is a harry potter show
planned for hbo
but it's really not what i expected or
what we all would have expected
coming to hbo is a harry potter quiz
show
to celebrate the dedicated fans old and
new who have passionately kept the
wizarding world magic alive
in so many forms for decades these
exciting specials will celebrate the
harry potter fandom
in a must-see multi-platform tv event
essentially what we're getting is this
two wizarding world tv specials that
will cover a five nights harry potter
trivia event this event is to celebrate
the 20th anniversary of the film release
of harry potter and the philosopher's
stone
the event itself will see harry potter
superfans gearing up
and competing against each other in
harry potter themed trivia
apparently there will be some special
guests and it looks like it's going to
be quite an exciting magical evening
so what do i think about all of this
first things first
i think that it's exciting that new
harry potter content is being made
in any format i'm a harry potter fan
it's as simple as that
so if they're making things in good fun
that don't contradict canon
whether that's a quiz show or anything
else i'm happy
however i'd be lying if i said that i
wasn't disappointed that all of my prior
predictions about the show
were wrong a quiz show sounds great and
i'm happy to have new content but a show
outlining the origins of dumbledore or
snape
would have been a lot better maybe
that's still something for the future
what do you guys think are you excited
for this event let me know
in the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard houry
you